do you know what blockchain is not
really do you know what Bitcoin is sort
of it's digital money that people use
computers to mine and it's worth heaps
and it's really unstable and it might be
the way of the future and I think
bitcoins are made with blockchain I'm
going to ask a computer scientist to
break it down for me in a time it takes
an elevator to go from the bottom of the
building up to the top and then all the
way back down which kind of looks like a
long time but I don't think it is going
to be because what is Gluck chain let's
go see
[Music]
Oh
hi Richard hey ready so you're ready to
do this yeah challenge accepted are you
excited to teach me everything you know
making me tense it's only one elevator
trip what's the worst that could happen
Bruce Willis ready
what is blockchain blockchain is a way
of taking information electronic
information and making it unchangeable
so people can't tamper with it in the
future but it's related to money isn't
it it's often used for money for crypto
currency like Bitcoin to keep a track of
all the transactions that have happened
so people can't lie about them later on
okay so the Bitcoin is like the cache
and the blockchain is the ledger it's a
ledger exactly right so why would people
pick cryptocurrency over other forms of
money mainly it's because it doesn't
need any trust you don't need to trust
the parties like PayPal they actually
just passed around to everyone multiple
people have it so if you try and change
it there's multiple other guys yeah yeah
okay and what is a blockchain like what
have lock and chain yeah yeah so the
block is where you store the
transactions so you can think of it as
like I don't know the transactions are
lining up outside there's a taxi coming
the first taxi that pulls up or jumps on
that's the block it holds all the
transactions yes to create a block you
need to solve a puzzle
definitely the puzzles is the
interesting bit all right so what are
the puzzles when the blockchain protocol
was set up initially they designed a
schema a way of generating an infinite
sequence of puzzles each puzzle takes
about ten you can't each puzzle takes
about ten minutes to solve with lots of
computing power everyone's working
flat-out to solve them because a person
that solves the puzzle gets to make the
next block and every time you make a
block you get paid some money and no one
owns the puzzle no one owns a puzzle the
puzzle is just the rules of maths no one
knows the answer until you find it okay
and the neat thing about it is each
puzzle relates to the previous solution
to the previous block so the blocks are
tied together in that way
that's what gives us a chain the blocks
are all linked together by the ways the
puzzles are structured so if you wanted
to change your block later on you'd
actually have to change all the ones
after it because all the puzzles would
be different that makes it
it's hard to fraud it that's right okay
so is this the best way to be having
money now so it's good because you don't
have to trust the government or anyone
like that but it's risky because if
something goes wrong then of course
everything's lost so why are we doing it
then it can't be used for anything else
there's so much hype I'm really glad you
asked this is a hundred and eighty-seven
things that people claim it can be used
for other than cryptocurrencies cancer
cells cancer it solves global warming it
solves AIDS and also online sales of
classic Japanese domestic cars is real
is it this is the problem it's great for
cryptocurrency it's not clear that it's
good for anything else
but everyone wants to use it so everyone
talks about it all the time well this is
my floor so I guess I'll go read this
Thank You Roble you're right see you're
at accept what do I do now so I think I
know what blockchain is now basically
it's a ledger where there are blocks
that are the carriers for transactions
and you get a block by solving an
mathematical puzzle and when you create
the block you get some money so you're
paid for having the block which carries
the transactions and then that block
gets put into a chain and they're all
linked together so that you can't fake
it you have to have the previous block
in the chain to be able to have the new
block and that's what makes it safe but
it's not really safe this is the really
scary part if everyone just stops
working on it it will cease to exist
and that'll be it it's crazy so I'm
really interested to see if any of this
list comes true particularly whether it
can solve a whole lot of problems
hopefully hey I hope you enjoyed this
little shortcut to smartness Richard
also actually has a lot of videos up on
YouTube of his lectures about computer
science and these are proper lectures
you can basically get a uni degree for
free so if you want to see any of those
we will put the link in the description
and you can go check it out if there's
any big topics that you would like us to
make elevator sighs and then let us know
in the comments below and you know I'll
see what I can do for you thanks for
watching